vega de varville found her happily ever
after with Prince Harry and on Friday
get ready for another case of royal
wedding fever as his cousin Princess
Eugenie says I do so here is what we
know
expect a star-studded guest list when
the daughter of Prince Andrew and his
ex-wife Sarah Ferguson says I do to Jack
Brooks Bank both of the Clooney's Amal
and George are expected at the wedding
on Friday there's also speculation that
Randy Gerber and his wife Cindy Crawford
will be there too Jack works for
George's tequila company Casa migas
supermodels Kate Moss and Naomi Campbell
are close to the bride and demi moore is
really tight with Sarah Ferguson
Princess Eugenie is rare for a royal
because she holds a real job
the bride is 9th in line to the throne
but she is a working private individual
she is not funded by the royal family
she is an art director at a well-to-do
gallery here in Mayfair in London
Eugenie's maid of honor will be her
older sister Princess Beatrice Prince
George will be a pageboy and Princess
Charlotte a bridesmaid
the Queen's oldest great grandchild
Savannah Phillips will also be a
bridesmaid and we're just hoping for
another cheeky moment like this there's
a rumor that Harry and Megan may only go
to the ceremony but could skip the
evening reception we're told that
several of Prince Harry's exes will be
there
Chelsea Davie has apparently been
invited Cressida Bonas best friends of
the bride and possibly the princes
wanting to avoid any awkward encounters
with his exes
[Music]